I'm seen one [ __ ] I'm an architect and I
also deal in master planning and urban
design good design actually is very
important because it uplifts the human
spirit so if there's any philosophy in
my work is always about how to design
spaces and environments that uplifts the
human spirit hot pot is a very unusual
project we saw the idea of a pavilion
structure that speaks about the site
then to us that view is very rare in
Singapore and to be able to capture that
veal and use it to synthesize the whole
experience about the place what it does
is it frames a view that changes a
perception of the place so i think that
building really is one of those most
satisfying buildings that we have ever
designed while you aspire to have some
sense of good design in your work in the
practice of architecture you have to
press on with your vision you have to
have that discipline and rigor to
overcome all the obstacles that's always
true in a way part of the whole training
has been to be very single-minded about
ensuring that your ideas on paper
eventually get to see the light of the
day that's residence is a result of our
own analysis of the site which is
undulating what is interesting in
Dutchess is that we were quite
successful in and ensuring that the
internal space within the site is
transformed into a very idyllic tropical
garden the integration of architecture
and the outdoors so in that sense
Dutchess is an example of the constant
ideas we always infuse in our works
Frank's begin I think the more important
role of PDA is to make it public to
educate a society so that we could level
up the appreciation of what design is
all about
because I think at the end of the day
the choices that people make in choosing
anything they want would have a bearing
on the standard design the society my
advice emerging designers always stay
true to what you want to do always be
deeper into our own backyard so to speak